[Applaudissements]
alors comment ces gens là qui viennent
mais les sur scène je vois pas très bien
ce que quelqu'un le courage que vient
vider le vote tous à moins de temps mais
surtout parce que je suppose que vous
êtes super venelles n'y a je l'aï pas ok
vous avez comment et maintenir les
allergies non seulement vous allez de
chine entre le public et nous à l'arc en
ciel vous imagine que le corps la cancel
orange rouge le ramassant je me réponds
c'est un paysage membres rencontrent les
couples aux parents c'est doublement mal
à aller si nous allons être regardés
penser aux paysages imaginés tous les
âges
est ce que vous pensez à la plage
la mer parce que le but de gérer une
enveloppe dans la poche et dans cet
angle augmenté cris yoann gourcuff s'est
ensuite parle pas anglais ça veut dire
je suis rentré chez moi alors je
m'adresse aujourd'hui 11é choriev
comment il faut les registres et
aujourd'hui je pars de dire je suis le
seul souvenir c'est que déjà la bombe
créatif et non seulement la créatine
gossip zapping folie qui veulent bien
nourrir cette créativité est géré ce
mode de pensée sous le terme choisi ti
sa vie en anglais les crazy fou et que
les ssii créée gêne vous voulez mais ce
soir soit partir du vêtement folk web
impossible ne rassure pas ce qu'elle
faisait d'elle qui se révéler ce qu'ils
vont être intéressantes
on va faire une belle aux vêtements
loufoque absous l'on sait qu'elle va
nous ouvrir des portes
après si rien n'était impossible par
exemple et ça c'est que déjà à l'achat
j'ai créé l'illusion intelligent de
l'impossible et en plus rares et les
ministres qui sont actuellement est bien
à l'épave puis ce sera comment fait on
va vous trompez utile et en plus de ça
on doit rajouter un élan surprise un
élément dont j'ai été et ça aussi
seulement de la créativité et un disque
folie est on arrivé à ces réponses et la
solution parce que c'est une question
très simple il a estimé autre match et
s'en va se dire et si et si je m'énerve
voler comme sa bande et s'y trouvait
lire dans les pensées ravi et si je vais
transformer le moins un grand voyage
singes reconnu qu'ils achètent
et quand on pense à toutes les
inventions du sort du melville les
avancées les hommes étaient comme l
imaginaire et d'industrie derrière et si
chaud ce musée un grand temps plein
milieu du désert en fond de pyramide
avec des pierres bien lourde
moi aussi mais on se mesure moyens et si
je l'étais ce gars sur la lune la nuit
la nuit
et si je refusais n'est pas nous qui
puisse assurer des rayons du soleil pour
le transforme en eau douce
tout est possible en danse comme ça
parce qu'elle est investi ici on va non
seulement accélérer le continent est
bonne les solutions qui vont être bien
aussi accepter cette image horrible nul
bête qui paraît sachant pas s'ils vont
nous guider vers les solutions dix mois
elle possible en fait va briser les noms
de l'industrie ces questions différentes
vous donner les réponses fiables dans
cette même phase aller
et qui consomme comme ça aujourd'hui
parmi les 100 femmes bien encore que les
enfants qui par saison va façonner par
les règles de la société parce qu'ils
ont façonné par éducation parle à
l'école d'une énergie ils peuvent france
encore de manière limitée on a arrêté de
le faire moi je pense que nos parents
nous professa ils ont dit certaines
phrases le bénin s'est détendu entendu
pire deuxième place à y donner
eiser 2006 soit réaliste
regardez autour de vous avec beaucoup de
chrome os mais bon en défense ça les
autres second était petit des légistes
presseront faire des bêtises quand c'est
n'importe quoi c'est sûrement nous
ennuie pas mais je romps des cris des
enfants ou les adultes on a des
compétences une expérience un savoir et
on peut reprendre cette crise il y six
grands politiques secret ici notre
enfance et la gomina et vous donne
aujourd'hui ce genre de conseils sont
belles phrases de jack ma je connaissais
sicard qui a fondé alibaba qui l'amazone
chinois quand même plus de 23 heures
ça va mais qu elle aussi en belgique qui
se donne en concert devant 108 de ses
employés alors que vous sentez
et au belge a clôt fou et il est fou
c'est bien on est fou on n'est pas bête
on serre sont belles et ça les fait ce
qu'ils savent faire moi j'ai fait un
pari fou je me suis dit et si je vous
mets par la régie soucier sur des ongles
et si je disais à mes parents voilà
c'est malin peuvent en europe mais j'ai
au courage à deux mains et je m'en
souviens c'était une belle après midi du
mois d'août sur la terrasse par un seul
terme à une journée parfaite pour
l'harmoniser et je dis bon moment je
réfléchis et j'arrivais à faire je vais
réussir à collectionner et la mère elle
a rigolé
alors si c'est une blague la rade et
m'ont permis d'être au calme et réfléchi
c'est les bras croisés ce que ça va se
faire c'est que c'est un cherchant à
être massivement toute sa vie et son
métier chercher et là je pense
effectivement le chercher une solution à
wohlen quand je les ai je me suis dit ça
va être dur mais je me suis donné les
moyens de faire je vous pose ces gens là
où il s'était servi ce débat que je
savais ce que je faisais même si elle
est folle
je serai la porte lors du salon donne un
t rex de doc / au verdict
la bonne nouvelle c'est elle a besoin de
devenir magicien pour apple selon vous
aussi vous avez de la cre estime qu'il
faut si on pouvait lire ici et si je
veux être promu aux si je pouvais être
aux bleus
[Musique]
et si je veux trouver la femme de ma vie
de m'engueuler terrain 2010 tout est
possible quand ça mais maintenant
j'entends certains outils qui ont bien
utile super à contrôler après à l'écran
avec mon projet et que l'on veut
réaliser selon fesses on est coincé mais
en réalité et c'est une facette de la
discussion
l'autre facette de se dire saucisse avec
question avec un grand projet des grands
lève et ça va me manquer un gros
problème et de grosses vagues
une position c'est que ce spectacle sont
que des illusions l'enseignante me
semble aussi et si je m'étais a voulu
qu'un savant savoir où les âmes 6-4
c'est impossible parce que c'est bien
beau mais là oui sauf si c'est rageant
mais c'est très rare le suivante est
donc simple souci c'est très fort et
très récent mais on est là qu avec la
ligue arabe et remplacera possible sauf
si on interdisait lumière on était un
peu la fumée dans de sérieuses et des
zooms sont bêtes et des dettes
on s'approche tout ça m'évite de
solutions qui vont un via les moins
intéressants en se disant ceci et c'est
exactement ce que j'avais tout à l'heure
avec notre avis qu'est ce qui s'est
passé jeudi et si je vais lire dans ses
pensées comme ça tu vas pouvoir et si je
pouvais donner l'illusion en influençant
mêlée cette fois qu'il avait eu à faire
si elle prévoir tout ce qu'elle a pu
dire c'est exactement ce que j'ai fait
je vis de penser à quelques couleurs de
l'arc en ciel que j'ai essayé
d'influencer la marche pas ce qu'est ce
que je dis je des mariages de couleurs
jour de ma porte et j'ai claqué des
doigts après l'été quand vous double peu
importe
et quand vous dites dans un paysage en
général vous pensez à la plage sur le
sable de l'année 9
[Musique]
mais non vous n'êtes pas une femme
l'avait dit non c'est pas aux plages de
la mer
et je vous ai dit c'est pas grave parce
que j'avais une enveloppe dans la poche
il ya écrit les lèvres à la mer mais si
vous avez dit vous avez dit la jouerai
oui c'est impossible sauf si j'avais
dans l'eau j'ai écrit effectivement way
s'il avait dit un truc improbable
planche enfin de chance j'aimerais que
ça je chante sans fleurs des champs de
vignes j'ai aussi à bouger la kossi
j'avais montagnes aux cimes
le post elle aussi aussi sur toi ça va
très vite ses marques françaises sont en
angola
ouais c'était pas si jamais il a à le
livre blanc français lol ah bah c'est
sûr tard j'ai découvert la régie
simplement amoureux du mode devancé les
airs quand les gens disent mc nuancée
qu'un exemple des angles génial sans
avoir mieux de lunel salavat régiment 5
infos j'ai aussi ma passion pour faire
des achats
et encore une fois vous avez pas besoin
de s'appeler pour le kart pour intégrer
tous aussi variés et si pas envie de
socié
même si les risques semblent aussi le
grand ben ali copperfield tracé laboral
de chiper disparaître à cette liberté
le seul magicien milliardaire cléac'h
est une île on l'a bien dit le timbre
dans la vie si paris veut dire
j'aimerais et de dire je vais considérer
que revient départs possibles sont
aujourd'hui dans l'autre sens aussi
comme cet arrêt donne un avant goût aux
gens ils pouvaient poser le label a
positivement
je pense que je peux améliorer la
communication d'entreprise ça
s'améliorera jk de l'impossible
pauvre chose que je pourrais lancer ma
propre affaire ça va coûter son propre
boss est impossible oui ça aussi mais
beaucoup c'est impossible sauf si ça
aussi d'améliorer la communication
d'entreprise
sauf si besoin c'est ça et que vous
voulez améliorer sa communication aussi
vous proposer aux collègues d'autres
départements de faire des à 3 800 points
cédant sa part variable
sauf si pour isaac on a juste voulu
faire oublier qu'ils appellent encore
parce que j'ai fait seulement voulons
donc en réalité mal six ans un métier et
surtout on évalue ce coût complet tous
un temps pourri que tous intérêts en jeu
tous mettre en oeuvre pour tenir
est-ce que ça va mal polis tout pareil
miracle comme ça ouais alors gens là ont
besoin de quelqu'un cette fois ci le
lance de notre aide a ajouté la manière
vous avez des neiges neige c'est vrai
c'est votre annonce je suis ok j'ai
appris sur le moral vous allez tous
viendront pas dit quand certaines
compagnies mais de l'autre côté
côté beauté douter et on va prier pour
qu'il se passe rien alors on en arrive
dans certains spectacles que soient
entendus l'alliance disparaissent donc
j'ai une bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle
maintenant sous series possible derrière
un voile à ces jo qu'une global mais la
bonne nouvelle que je sais ça toujours
ce genre de troubles dans les
conférences traditionnelles et du coup
j'ai un petit cadeau pour seulement un
petit paquet inscrire votre nom dessus
c'est bien beau les gens c'est pour elle
et dans ce même si l'âme au mouvement
dont j
il y à un cadeau pour vous
j'arrive j'avais remporté de justesse 1
alors déjà quelque chose qui va beaucoup
plaire c'est que tout ce que je trouve
pour le moment c'est du gâchis
tenez ce sera pour commencer j'ai aussi
un autre papier remet tous les papiers
et un derrière vous avez trouvé
parce qu'on met à la lumière ainsi
surnommé bongoland vos rapports
diana
vous pouvez ouvrir ce cas là je reprends
le ta vie' enfin moi je reprends
doucement pouvait pas tenir longtemps
ouvrez n'est pas couché avant tout il
est bien fermée de tous les côtés un
briefing au mail de son énergie à
hésiter
[Musique]
superbe nom l indique à ce que vous
trouvez je prends le cassoulet vous
pouvez dire d'autre que vous voyez un
intérieur est une autre femme arabe ofa
est ce que vous vient cet autre petit
bois super spéciale intérieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]